DEAL ON DACA WHICH MAY BE AN
INDICATOR OF WHAT HAPPENS ON
GUNS.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
AS WE SAID, NOT ALL REPUBLICANS
ON THE SAME PAGES
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHEN IT COMES TO
TARIFFS AND WHAT HE    HE SAID O
TARIFFS AND WHAT HE    HE SAID
TARIFFS AND WHAT HE    HE SAID U
TARIFFS AND WHAT HE    HE SAID N
CONTROL.
NEBRASKA SENATOR BEN SASSE HAS
SOME SERIOUS PROBLEMS ABOUT WHAT
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN SAYING.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT STEEL AND
ALUMINUM.
YOU HAVE A REAL PROBLEM WITH
WHAT THE PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED
TODAY.
>> TRADE IS GREAT FOR AMERICA.
IT'S GREAT FOR AMERICAN
FAMILIES.
NO TRADE WAR HAS EVER WORKED.
WE DON'T WANT TO MAKE AMERICA
1930 AGAIN.
THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN OF
AMERICA DON'T WANT TO BE DRAFTED
INTO A TRADE WAR.
IT DOESN'T WORK.
TRADE CREATES JOBS.
TRADE LOWERS PRICES FOR AMERICAN
FAMILIES.
TRADE WARS DO THE OPPOSITE.
>> Bret: YOUR STATEMENT WAS
READ TO SARAH SANDERS TODAY.
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT THE
PRESIDENT WILL OR SHOULD HAVE OR
APOLOGIZE FOR AMERICAN WORKERS.
CERTAINLY NOT TO SENATOR SASSE.
>> THE PRESIDENT RAN ON THIS.
HE FEELS STRONGLY ABOUT IT.
WHEN I TALK TO HIM, ITS WORKERS,
RANCHERS, FARMERS.
WAGES AND JOBS.
THE PRESIDENT'S OBJECTIVE IS WE
HAVE TO GIVE MORE JOBS BACK TO
AMERICA.
REDUCE THE DEFICIT.
THAT WILL ULTIMATELY PUT
PRESSURE ON WAGES.
>> Bret: DO YOU BELIEVE THERE
ARE COUNTRIES THAT ARE DUMPING
STEEL?
>> THERE ARE.
THERE ARE LAWS WE SHOULD USE FOR
DISPUTE RESOLUTION.
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU START
DOWN A TRADE WAR PATH.
IF YOU OWN A STEEL MILL, TODAY
WAS GREAT FOR YOU.
IF YOU CONSUME STEEL, AND EVERY
AMERICAN FAMILY AT THE STORE
BOUGHT SOMETHING THAT HAS METALS
IN IT.
TODAY IS A BAD DAY FOR YOU.
WHEN THE TRADE WAR GETS WORSE,
THERE'S GOING TO BE RETALIATORY
TARIFFS AGAINST THE FARMERS AND
RANCHERS AMERICA AND THE
PRODUCERS AND THE WORKERS OF
AMERICA.
WE'RE GOING TO LOSE AS CONSUMERS
AND PRODUCERS.
>> Bret: TO EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE
AT HOME, THERE ARE COUNTRIES WHO
CHARGE MORE FOR STEEL AT HOME
AND THEN PUT THEIR STEEL IN THE
U.S. AT A LOWER PRICE WHICH THEN
BURDENS THOSE COMPANIES.
IF YOU TALK TO THE STATES WHERE
THEY SAW MANY, MANY JOBS LEAVE,
A LOT OF THOSE STATES
DONALD TRUMP WON BY 55, 60, 65%.
THEY ARE SAYING WHY NOT
REPATRIATE THE AMERICAN SUPPLY
CHAIN AND DO IT HERE.
>> WHAT TRADE HAS DONE OVER THE
LAST DECADES, IT'S DRIVEN DOWN
PRICES FOR AMERICAN CONSUMERS
AND CREATED JOBS.
THERE ARE ALL SORTS OF
CHALLENGES WITH WHAT CHINA DOES
BUT WHAT THAT REQUIRES IS THAT
WE ENGAGE MORE IN ASIA PACIFIC
NOT PULLBACK.
>> Bret: THIS PRESIDENT HAS
ALREADY SAID, HE RAN ON IT.
HE WASN'T GOING TO BE IN THE TPP
HE WASN'T GOING TO BE IN THE TP
TPP.
AND HE RAN AROUND THE COUNTRY ON
THIS PLATFORM.
THE COUNTRY ELECTED HIM.
FOR PEOPLE WHO SAY WHY DOESN'T
THAT MATTER, HOW DO YOU RESPOND?
>> THIS IS LEFTIST ECONOMIC
POLICY.
WE TRIED IT A BUNCH OF TIMES
OVER THE LAST TWO CENTURIES.
EVERY TIME, AMERICAN FAMILIES
HAVE SUFFERED.
IT IS BAD POLICY.
I GET THAT THE PRESIDENT RAN ON
THIS BUT THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH
OF ISSUES, ONCE HE GOT IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, HE STARTED
LISTENING TO ADVISORS.
HIS REGULATORY REFORM AGENDA HAS
BEEN GREAT.
THIS TRADE POLICY WILL BE
DISASTROUS.
>> Bret: THE OTHER THING YOU
HAVE A CONCERN ABOUT IS WHAT HE
SAID ABOUT GUNS.
BASICALLY DUE PROCESS.
HE HAS SINCE, THE WHITE HOUSE
HAS SINCE WALKED BACK THAT AND
SAID HE WASN'T TALKING ABOUT
AFFECTING THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
YOU KIND OF JUMPED ON IT PUT OUT
A STATEMENT.
>> HERE IS WHAT AMERICA MEANS.
IT MEANS WE BELIEVE RIGHTS COME
TO US FROM GOD VIA NATURE AND
GOVERNMENT EXISTS TO SECURE AND
PROTECT OUR RIGHTS.
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T GIVE US
RIGHTS.
WHEN YOU SAY SOMETHING LIKE TAKE
THE GUNS FIRST.
GRAB THE GUNS FIRST AND LATER WE
WILL HAVE DUE PROCESS.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS GOVERNMENT'S
FIRST AND HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE A
BUREAUCRAT YOU TRUST TO DECIDE
WHAT RIGHTS YOU HAVE.
THAT'S NOT HOW AMERICA WORKS.
AMERICAN CITIZENS HAVE THE WHOLE
BILL OF RIGHTS AVAILABLE TO THEM
AND IN THE CASES OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE DERANGED OR HAVE COMMITTED
CRIMES, THEN WE DO DUE PROCESS
AND TAKE AWAY CERTAIN PRIVILEGES
THEY HAVE.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK THERE IS
A POSSIBILITY OF GETTING
SOMETHING ON SCHOOL SAFETY AND
GUNS OUT OF THE CONGRESS?
>> I THINK YESTERDAY YOU SAW
DAVID FRENCH ISSUE A PROPOSAL
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE WAS PAYING
SOME ATTENTION TO.
DIDN'T GET A LOT OF PLAY IN
YESTERDAY'S REALITY TV
GOVERNANCE MEETING THEY DID.
DAVID FRENCH WAS TALKING ABOUT
GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS.
THERE IS INTEREST IN THAT.
IN THE CASES OF PEOPLE WITH
MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS, WE
SHOULD DO SOMETHING TO MAKE SURE
THEY CAN'T GET ACCESS TO
WEAPONS.
THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN VIA DUE
PROCESS, NOT THROUGH SOME
BUREAUCRAT WHO GETS TO
PREORDAINED WHO GETS WHAT
FIRST AMENDMENT AND
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
>> Bret: UNDERSTANDING YOU
DON'T LIKE WHAT HE SAID AT THE
MEETING, THERE WERE A LOT OF
PEOPLE LOVED AT THE MEETING ON
IMMIGRATION AND THE MEETING ON
GUN CONTROL SAY IT'S OPEN.
HE HAS DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
THROWING OUT IDEAS.
WHY IS THAT SO BAD TO BE TALKED
ABOUT IN A NEGATIVE LIGHT AS
REALITY TV?
>> TRANSPARENCY IS GREAT BUT YOU
DON'T TRY TO REWRITE THE
CONSTITUTION SHOOTING FROM THE
HIP.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU SAW
YESTERDAY WHEN YOU SAW
DIANNE FEINSTEIN GIDDY, ECSTATIC
ABOUT THE IDEA THAT THERE WILL
BE NEW GUN BAN IN AMERICA.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN, SENATOR.
YOU ARE THERE TO PREVENT THAT
FROM HAPPENING IN THIS PRESIDENT
ISN'T GOING TO PUSH THAT, IS HE?
>> I AM EXCITED BY THE FACT THE
WHITE HOUSE TODAY SAID A BUNCH
MORE TRULY AMERICAN THINKS ABOUT
THE BILL OF RIGHTS AND WHAT
RIGHTS AMERICAN CITIZENS HAVE.
YESTERDAY IN THE MEETING, THE
TAPE IS THE TAPE.
IF YOU SAY YOU ARE GOING TO GRAB
GUNS FIRST AND WORRY ABOUT DUE
PROCESS LATER, THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING YOU GIVE YOUR
LISTENERS AND VIEWERS A LOT OF
COMFORT.
>> Bret: YOU ARE CHARACTERIZED
AS A SENATOR CRITICAL OF THIS
PRESIDENT.
YOU, SENATOR FLAKE,
SENATOR CORKER.
FAIR?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
PUNDITS LOVE TO JOB ON -- JUMP
ON ISSUES.
I AM PRINCIPAL BY PRINCIPAL.
>> Bret: LET'S GO DOWN THE
LIST OF HIS ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
TAX REFORM.
NEIL GORSUCH.
>> WONDERFUL.
FIGHTING FOR THE JUDGES.
HE HAS NOMINATED GREAT JUDGES.
>> Bret: MOST FEDERAL APPEALS
COURT JUDGES.
>> CHUCK GRASSLEY IS NOT A GREAT
PROCESS.
WE SET THE ALL-TIME RECORD.
>> Bret: PERMIT FOR THE
KEYSTONE PIPELINE, OTHER ENERGY
MOVES.
>> REGULATORY FORMED BY THIS
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN STRONG.
>> Bret: 860 OBAMA REGULATIONS
SUSPENDED.
THE U.S. EMBASSY FROM TEL AVIV
TO JERUSALEM.
MILITARY CRACKDOWN ON ISIS ARE
USUALLY SEEN AS FORCING TO
RETREAT FROM IRAQ AND SYRIA.
>> A LOT OF PROGRESS.
>> Bret: WITHDRAW FROM THE
PARIS CLIMATE AGREEMENT.
>> YES.
>> Bret: AND FORCE THE REDLINE
AND SYRIA.
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" OP-ED SAYS
THE ONLY GOOD THING ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP IS HIS POLICIES.
FAIR TO SAY THERE ARE A LOT OF
THINGS THIS PRESIDENT HAS DONE
THAT YOU ARE DEFINITELY
SUPPORTIVE OF, BUT HOW HE TALKS
ABOUT THAT OR HIS COMMUNICATION
OF IT AND HOW HE COMPORTS
HIMSELF, YOU HAVE A PROBLEM.
>> NO, THAT'S NOT MY PROBLEM.
I AM THE SECOND MOST
CONSERVATIVE SENATOR BY VOTING
RECORD AND 1 OF 5 PEOPLE IN THE
U.S. SENATE HAS NEVER BEEN A
POLITICIAN BEFORE.
WE NEED DISRUPTION.
THE CITY DOESN'T WORK.
ONE OF THE GREAT THINGS ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT AS IT US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT BUSINESS
AS USUAL THINGS THAT DON'T WORK.
I SUPPORTED THE VAST MAJORITY OF
WHAT HE IS DONE.
JUDGES CHIEF AMONG THEM BUT AT
THE LEVEL OF BASIC CIVICS, WE
HAVE A CRISIS THAT THE NEXT
GENERATION DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
THE AMERICAN IDEA.
41% OF AMERICANS UNDER AGE 35
TELL POLLSTERS THEY THINK THE
FIRST AMENDMENT IS DANGEROUS.
ON THE LEFT YOU HAVE ALL BUNCH
OF PEOPLE DISINTERESTED IN
RELIGIOUS LIBERTY.
BOWLING TELLS US THAT YOU HAVE A
BUNCH OF PEOPLE DISINTERESTED IN
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS.
THE FREEDOMS OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT, THEY ARE
BUNDLED UP AS ONE THING.
WE ARE NOT DOING A BETTER JOB OF
CIVICS.
WHEN YOU SAY THINGS FROM THE
BULLY PULPIT OF GRAB THE GUNS
FIRST AND DEAL WITH DUE PROCESS
LATER, THAT DOESN'T HELP SOLVE
THE CIVICS PROBLEMS.
MY CONCERNS ARE ABOUT PASSING ON
THE AMERICAN IDEA OF A FREE
REPUBLIC.
AT THE LEVEL OF POLICY, THERE'S
A BUNCH OF STUFF I'M DOING TO